افاده مراسل الجزيره بان سلسله انفجارات
تهز مدنها كراماتوستوفيا
في مقاطعه دوناتسكو ومعنى من كرامه تورس
المراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج اخر تطورات هذا
القصف في هذه الجبهه من الحرب
قريبه قادمه من ستافيا كذلك الامر من
كونستاني
رشققات الصواريخ او الهجمات الصاروخيه
التي تعرضت لها تعرضت لها مختلف المدني
والبلدات في هذه الجبهه حتى في مناطق اخرى
كما ذكرته في الخبر كيف جوتيمر لميسكي
اضافه الى ميكو لايف خيرسون اذا طريجيا
ودي نيبروه وصوره الى الجبهات الشرقيه
مقتل شخص وايضا اصابه همم اخر همم الاركان
هنا وايضا السلطات المحليه تصف هذه
العمليات بانها نوع من الارهاب وايضا في
محاوله
التنكيد على الناس او همم ذهابي فرحه
العيد هنا كما تعلم راس السنه بالنسبه في
اوكرانيا وبالتالي هذا هو القسط كما
يقولون والا ان هذه الصواريخ لم تستهدف اي
اهداف عسكريه سواء وحتى في ميكو لايف كل
الجرحى الذين سقطوا من المدنيين ولكن هذا
ايضا همم هو استكمال
العمليات العسكريه التي خاصه في الجهه
الشرقيه والجنوبيه هنا اليوم كان هناك
تقدم للقوات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه لوهاسكو
ايضا في محوري عن القوات الاوكرانيه تعلن
عن اقتران للسيطره على مدينه كريمينا التي
بدات هذه المعركه منذ نحو شهرين وحاكم
المقاطعه مقاطعه قال ان القوات اوكرانيه
على وشك السيطره عليها وهذا يفتح الباب
للسيطره على المدن الرئيسيه التي خسرتها
القوات الاوكرانيه منتصف العام همم العام
الحالي همم تحديدا لاستشانس وايضا همم
روبينا كذلك الامر
القوات الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن انسحاب عدد
كبير من القاده الروس من هذه المناطق قاده
الانفصاليه وتوجههم الى مناطق اكثر امنا
وايضا حديث للاستخبارات الاوكرانيه تقول
ان المقاتلين الروس في تلك المناطق
مستعدون للتسليم في حاله اطبقه القوات
الاوكرانيه الحصار على هذه المنطقه ايضا
في جبهته لها تشهد ركودا في اليومين
الماضيين مقارنه مع الايام السابقه
والاسبوع الماضي كان هناك همم اخذ ورد
وايضا يتقدم للقوات الروسيه تابعه استعاده
السيطره على الناطق التي حازتها القوات
الروسيه من قبل الجيش الاوكرانيا يعني
الوضع اليوم متصاعد كما ذكرت قبل قليل
سلسله الانفجارات هزت هنا اكرامي تورس
وايضا المدن في الشرق هناك تحضيرات منها
هجمات قد تتكرر خلال ساعات الليل في هذه
المناطق حتى في مناطق اخرى
عمر الحاج من كاباتا مراسل الجزيره شكرا
جزيلا لك